to drive around myanmar cities
everyday life might look like it's
normal
but look a little closer roads are
closed with barriers barricaded military
positions and uniformed soldiers on the
streets
i saw the army destroyed the protest
after that i was very afraid that's why
i'm scared to go out again
but there were more protests beside my
house so i joined if i feel safe i would
join the protest
myanmar has been ravaged by covert 19 in
the past 12 months
the situation intensified after the
military targeted medical workers for
their involvement in protests and a
civil disobedience movement
many were arrested others fled into
hiding
today even basic health care services
are scarce
i won't forget the day that her workers
were arrested and treated very badly by
the army they evacuated a medical
student that's why i won't return to the
hospital
in the cities food remains plentiful but
prices have risen sharply
elsewhere supplies and production have
run dangerously low
the world food programme estimates it
needs to provide food for four million
people across myanmar in 2022 four times
the number before the coup
the economy has gone into free fall
banks limit withdrawals and foreign
investment is pulling out fast many
people
lose their jobs
and it is impeding to the
uh the labour market
and also
many people are jobless but
the many job seekers are
getting the job but being
baked less than normal
even basic services like trains and
buses are failing
the nationwide rail network has ground
to a halt after workers joined the civil
disobedience movement and bus prices
have tripled as operators abandoned
standardized rules
in my opinion if we get rid of army rule
transport services would go back to
normal with properly working buses and
normal ticket prices
historically the people of myanmar are
used to military rule but after a decade
of progress and development the last 12
months is leaving many feeling as if
they're returning to the past
not only are many many people being
affected by the results of this coup but
they're pushing back to right at the
moment inside myanmar there's a silent
protest going on a way people can safely
protest against the military coup we
understand that in most of myanmar's
major urban centers the streets have
fallen silent as people close businesses
and stay indoors to
demonstrate to the military that they do
not agree the military has been
arresting people it is very trying very
hard to squash the opposition i think in
a coup that is being felt so keenly by
so many people
at this stage many people in myanmar
just want them to get out thank you so
much tony chang reporting from the thai
myanmar border